(indistinct chatter)
(dramatic music)
- I was born in Texas.
My mom ventured out when she was 18
to go to someplace
other than our hometown,
she ended up in Texas
where she met my father.
She ended up getting pregnant with me
a couple of years later.
My dad actually left while
my mom was having me.
My mom was forced to go back to Indiana
with her parents where I grew up.
She raised me alone.
You know, she was a single parent.
She did a really great job at raising me.
You know, I had morals and ethics
and I learned how to treat people
the way that I wanted to be treated.
I was a really bad kid,
I was always getting in trouble
because I didn't have a
male role model in my life
to give me any kinda discipline I think.
And by the time I was 12,
I was getting kicked out of school,
and getting in trouble all the time,
and getting put on probation,
and different things like that.
(clears throat)
When my father came back
when I was 12 years old,
and he came back for a
very short period of time
where he was trying to be,
trying to be back in my life,
but he ended up just passing away,
like from a heart failure.
My mom was left to raise me by herself,
you know, and she did
the best that she could,
but I was a really bad kid.
I was 16 when I started using drugs
because I was, I had a injury to my leg.
I was in a pretty bad car accident.
And I was also in a, ooh!
Was also in a, I had a football injury
where I blew my other knee out.
So I got on to pain
medication at that time,
when I started using Vicodins,
and different things like that,
just to, you know, to ease the pain
I thought is was what I was doing,
but I didn't realize it was gonna cause
so many problems later on.
My mom was diagnosed with
cancer when I was 17,
she ended up beating that
first round of cancer,
but she also passed away a few years later
from cancer as well
when I was incarcerated.
I was 18 years old
when I've caught my
first charge as an adult.
I was just literally like one
week into my 18th birthday.
I didn't wanna go to jail.
I got caught with
Vicodin, ooh, not Vicodin,
I call it ecstasy, and
other pain pills as well.
They sentenced me to do
two years on probation,
but I violated within a year,
and I took off and didn't really come back
until I was in my mid twenties.
My family exported drugs
from another country
when I was in Portugal.
And I always wondered what
my dad's side of the family
did for a living.
They drove very expensive cars,
and never went, never worked,
and never went to a nine to five job.
And I always asked them
like, what they did,
you know, what, how do
they support themselves?
And I found out later on
that my family was manufacturing
a drug called Methaqualone,
which is Quaaludes,
for another name for those as Quaaludes.
When I was on the run
from my first charge,
I was able to get out of the country
and moved to Portugal
where I learned how to
manufacture this drug.
And I did that for, for
many years, for seven years,
until my uncle passed
away from cancer as well,
left me, you know, I planned
on making millions of dollars,
and being able to retire
at a very young age,
but it just didn't end
up working out that way.
When he passed away, I was
kinda left with nothing.
My, his wife took all the chemicals,
and all the glassware and
ended up selling it to somebody
that was outside of my family.
And I was left to
basically my own devices,
no money, no way to make a dollar,
I didn't know what I was gonna do.
So I went back home,
ended up catching another
charge for possession.
When I went into that last
time that I spent in jail,
I was doing a two year,
doing one sentence.
And I met a guy in there
who talks about heroin.
And I always thought that heroin
was like the biggest no-no,
the biggest thing that you shouldn't do.
And anybody that did it, was just like,
you know, not a good person.
But when I got out of jail,
I hit that person up and
he offered to take me
to another state to go
get some heroin one day,
which I thought about it for a while,
but I ended up going
and driving him to Ohio,
which is where we were gonna go
and get this heroin I guess.
When, the first time I tried heroin,
like, it was like the greatest thing
that's ever been created by God.
You know, it was something that
it changed my life entirely.
It was like a warm hug from my mom,
from my mother, you know,
it sort of reminded me of something
that just like kept me warm and fuzzy.
And it made me feel like there was like,
never gonna be anything else
that there was any better.
So at that time I was
living in a small town
where nobody really did heroin,
they were smoking pot and eating pills,
and doing things like that.
But when I discovered heroin,
I thought it was the
greatest thing in the world.
And so I wanted all my friends to try it,
you know, and all my friends to experience
what I was experiencing as well.
So I brought my first few bags of heroin
into this little small town,
where everybody knows who you are.
And it's a pretty, pretty crazy to think
that like, within like a year's time,
I was just like known
as like the heroin king,
of this little small town.
Like every, I had everybody coming to me
and getting bags and like I started
to getting watched by the police,
and things were going
downhill pretty quickly,
cause I was using all the time,
and constantly like trying
to figure out what's next
and living the lifestyle
like a rockstar almost, in my opinion.
Like I had a awesome car,
had a beautiful girlfriend,
tons of money.
And I was just living what I thought
was gonna be the rest of my life.
But again, it just didn't turn out that,
it didn't turn out the
way that I expected it to.
I got arrested for something,
it's pretty petty, my opinion,
it was just a Vicodin.
And when I got charges of Vicodin,
I got sentenced to do one sentence,
but it was a suspended due to probation,
and different things, that I
had to complete for classes,
and things like that.
I ended up meeting my
wife shortly after that.
She didn't want me to go to jail.
So I ended up moving into
her little small town.
We started selling
heroin to all the people
in that small town also.
The wife that I met was
something that was like,
she was 19, I was 25, something like that,
24 or 23, something in that area.
And I just fell in love with her.
And she was like my little
Bonnie and Clyde, I guess,
we were just going out and
doing destructive shit,
and buying heroin and
selling it to all her friends
and, you know, making lots of money.
But we both had a terrible habit.
Pretty shortly after that, the police came
to her little small town
where I was living in,
and ended up arresting me
for a violation of probation
that I had and just took me to jail.
When I got incarcerated
for that last time,
it was a pretty hard because my mom,
who is the only parent that I've ever had,
was diagnosed with cancer again.
She, they only gave her a year to live,
and I was gonna have to do a year in jail.
I did most of that time.
Like I was on a work release program.
So I was out in the world every day
and life wasn't so bad,
until I ended up catching
my wife cheating on me
with one of my closest friends.
She ended up actually trying to turn me in
to get me to do more jail time.
She'd met me, she met me somewhere
when I was on work release
and dropped off some things
for me to bring back
into the work release.
And she called the police and told them
that I was bringing things in,
and I almost got sentenced
to another 10 years or so
for bringing things into the jail.
Luckily I, smart enough
to kinda figure out
how to sit and wait for,
to get my opportunity
to get rid of what I needed to get rid of,
so that I wouldn't end up
having to do that time.
They, I sat in jail for
probably nine months
out of that year.
And they sent me to go to a rehab.
I went to my first rehab
which was at a mental hospital in Indiana.
Was there for a month,
at that time, that's when
I went to the hospital
and my mom, and the doctor,
and the families and everything was there.
And they told her that she
didn't have very long to live,
like weeks, two months,
something like that.
I was very angry and didn't
really know what I was gonna do,
but the rehab was extremely
not receptive for me
to going and seeing her.
So they escorted me to
the hospital in handcuffs
and would not leave the room
for my last visit with my
mom, it was really hard.
They escorted me back to the rehab.
And at that time, my wife showed up,
and she was, told me that
it was my birthday actually.
And she told me that she showed up,
she was extremely late
three, four hours late.
And when she showed up,
she was all fucked up.
I made her pull her arm, her sleeves up,
and that's when I found out
she was using heroin again.
And I ended up getting into a fight
with one of the people at the rehab
because I just found out my mom
was gonna have a few weeks left to live.
I just found out my wife
was using heroin again.
And that's when I kinda snapped, you know,
and beat one of the guys
that was working there,
half to death.
They took me in a room
that I didn't know what was gonna happen.
And then they sent me back
to jail the very next day.
No credited time of the
months that I've been there,
And when I went home or
when I went back to jail,
I had no idea when I
was gonna be released.
No idea when my mom was gonna pass away.
And I actually got sentenced
to do another nine months in jail.
At that time, I had nobody
putting money on my books.
I had nobody helping me.
So I was angry, I was hungry,
and I was doing what
I had to do to get by.
I had some guy there, who was
a, I'll never forget this,
he ended up, there was a time
where we were switching out
this ice bucket in the jail,
cause we had like one ice bucket a day,
that we could use for the whole day.
When this guy came up to me
and ask why I was
changing this ice bucket,
and he spilled a whole
cup of water over my head.
And he was laughing and
thinking it was hilarious.
And I just turned red.
I couldn't see anything
besides blood, man.
And I started fighting this guy
and I got him on the ground
and beat him until he
was flat black and blue.
And the police ran, you
know, police came in
and ended up putting me
in solitary confinement
for six months.
I did a cell by myself.
No idea of anything.
Like I had no money to order if anything,
no commissary, no nothing, no phone calls.
It was just me in a cell by myself,
and around nine months or so later,
like I had a, they just
came into my cell one day
and told me to pack my stuff up.
And I had no idea why
or what was going on,
but I was being released.
And when they released me and
my grandparents were there,
and they took me back to
their house where my mom was,
and I got to spend a few hours with her
before she ended up passing away.
When she passed away,
she left me some money
so that I could take care
of myself for, you know,
it's supposed to be a
longer period than it was,
but I ended up spending all
the money on drugs, on heroin.
At that time, my wife got a job.
We were working, both
working at a a gold place
where I was flying a sign
for like eight hours a day.
She ended up getting a job
inside with the gold place,
and ended up, she ended up like,
ended up sleeping with the guy
that was running this gold shop.
So that's what kinda
split our relationship up.
I got back with her again, later on.
And on Thanksgiving, I
was busy with my family
because you know, my family
didn't accept my wife
and my, they didn't, her family
didn't really like me either.
So we were doing separate Thanksgivings.
And I got, I went and did my
family thing and came home.
And when I came home, I got a phone call
from our friend's girlfriend,
that was telling me
that my wife was sleeping
with her husband, right now.
And I, the whole time I thought
she was with her family,
but I ended up going to where they were
and beating this guy, half to death.
My wife got into a fight with a girlfriend
of this other gentleman.
And that was kinda the
end of our relationship.
After my wife, I caught her with my friend
and luckily he didn't call,
I mean, the police came,
they were on the way as I was leaving.
I could hear them coming.
And I luckily I got away
and went back to my house
and I called my aunt who
lives here in Los Angeles
and I told her what was going on.
And she flew me out here to LA.
Shortly after that my wife had called me
and told me she was pregnant,
and that it was my kid.
So I told her that I
would be there for her
as much as I could.
And if the kid was mine, that
I would go back to Indiana
and I would be with her.
Nine months passed,
and not only was the child,
not my friends or mine,
The child came out black,
not that I'm racist or anything at all,
but it was definitely
not my child, you know.
So needless to say, that
was the end of my marriage.
I was broken, man, like lost my wife,
lost my mother, all
within like a year span.
And I started using heroin really heavy.
My aunt here is like a saint, man.
Like she's done everything
that she's could
to like try to get me
out of the drug game,
and trying to get me on a normal path.
But it's just not just not happened.
She's had me in and out of
rehabs and different places
that she thought was gonna change me,
but I always ended up back on the streets,
back using drugs and selling drugs,
and in and out of jail.
Since then, I've moved on to fentanyl,
heroin just wasn't
doing it for me anymore.
You know, I was doing black
tar heroin at the time,
and it just wasn't, it wasn't
getting me to the point
where it was when I first started using.
Fentanyl, took me right
back to that first time
that I did heroin.
You know, it gave me
everything I was looking for,
but it's also ruined my life, man.
I've not been able to do anything
besides sell drugs and lie
to my family ever since.
I've been homeless for
the first time this year.
Six months ago I had $50,000 in the bank.
I was selling fentanyl to everybody
that had ever heard of
it, you know, (laughs)
But pandemic hit, after the pandemic hit,
I was just unemployed.
I started using drugs even
heavier than I ever had before.
Kinda left now trying to figure out
what's next.
You know, so I've been homeless
now for just a few months,
staying with some friends,
but I still consider myself homeless.
I'm in a place that I
really don't wanna be,
dealing with people that
I don't wanna deal with,
you know spending time on Skid Row
for the first time in my life,
where I would never have
thought that I would ever be.
And I'm basically just waiting
to figure out what's next.
And I hope that something
eventually changes
so that I can stop using this
drug, man, cause I hate it.
I hate the way it's made me become.
I don't care about anything
besides staying well,
and trying to put a roof over my head.
That's about where I'm at today.
- [Male] Arthur, thank you so
much for sharing your story.
- Yeah.
- [Male] Good luck with everything, man.
- Thanks man, I appreciate it.
- You've been through a lot.
- I'm sure there's more to come
but I hope I can get through
all this bullshit, man.
- [Male] I know.
Thank you.
- All right, thanks.